outgoing defense secretary James Madison
dan order to pull all US troops out of
Syria and President Trump has ordered
mattis to leave the Pentagon by New
Year's Day that's right that's a change
the president turned down Madison
offered to stay through February after
the retired Marine general resigned over
the Syrian withdrawal and other issues
the deputy defense secretary former
Boeing executive Patrick Shanahan will
become the acting defense secretary and
our Arab arnett is at the White House
with reaction to the change of
leadership at the Pentagon
Errol not in mar-a-lago as you may have
expected this morning good morning
you're absolutely right Tony look what
happened here in Washington is that the
sudden departure of defense secretary
Jim mattis triggered widespread concern
here and president Trump's decision to
pull troops out of Syria is also being
met with significant criticism from both
his and the United States closest allies
at the heart of the issue here is the
president's implication that troops are
unnecessary because Isis in Syria is
decimated something many Republicans in
Congress disagree with but in a call
with Turkey's president that's wretched
type erawan mr. Trump said withdrawal of
the roughly 2000 troops would be slow
and highly coordinated now the president
also said erawan quote has very strongly
informed me that he will eradicate
whatever is left of Isis in Syria our
troops are coming home but that decision
has also angered several foreign policy
officials including Brett McGurk he is
the administration's top official in the
fight against Isis this is a crucial
role he resigned one day after Matt
assal though the president surprisingly
claimed he didn't even know McGurk what
are we now nearly two years into his
administration now what we know is with
those officials gone the team
spearheading troop withdrawal and
overseeing the fight against Isis will
see several new faces and what we don't
know is when those troops will return
home Adriana
Erol thanks